albert einstein la superstar des
sciences je pense que vraiment ils
méritent pas mal sous titres non
seulement parce qu'il a révolutionné la
physique de nombreuses reprises mais
aussi parce que c'est un mec qui était
l'événement très appréciable c'est
vraiment une idole quelqu'un auquel on
s'identifie et qu'elle aimerait
ressembler quand on est scientifique
alors on dit souvent que aïcha a été
mauvaise élève à l'école et je pense
qu'il ya une part de vrai dans le sens
où il n'était pas le bon élève à suivre
à prendre toutes les questions lever la
main être assis au premier rang et se
faisant jour il était un élève qui était
très très bon en maths et en physique
mais qui un peu négligé les autres
matières et avait un caractère un petit
peu rebelle qui finalement est un trait
assez récurrent je dirais chez pas mal
de grands génies comme cela quand j'ai
parlé avec eux alors la personne de john
nash et pour le coup einstein il se fait
pas vraiment remarqué pour son génie
quand il est étudiant et que ce sont
nous de ce côté un peu rebelle einstein
ne va pas avoir les bonnettes de
recommandations pour devenir un
professeur du coup une fois qu'il a fini
son doctorat au polytechnicum de zurich
il va être sans emploi à ce moment là il
va se marier avec mileva maric et avoir
un enfant en 1903 1904 est fini du coup
de par devoir accepter un job il se fait
pistonné pour l'avoir d'ailleurs et il
devient employé de bureau dans un bureau
de brevets où il doit valider ou
invalider des brevets bref un travail
qui correspond pas du tout à son génie à
priori mais ce travail lui donne
l'occasion de rêvasser de prendre le
temps de réfléchir aux choses et on dit
souvent que parmi les brevets qu'ils
avaient à lire et à valider il y en
avait pas mal qui concerne l acide
synchronisation des montres ou des
méthodes pour synchroniser les montres
qui était un gros problème à l'époque
puisque enfin jusque là les gens
utilisaient des montres qui
correspondait au soleil dont qui était
midi lorsque cela était
au casse comme ça au zénith le problème
avec cela c'est que midi diffèrent en
fonction de la longitude et du coup
entre paris et zurich
ce n'est pas la même heure ça ça posait
de gros problèmes sur il y avait des
trains qui se percutent et tout ça du
coup synchrone et le montre ce qui est
important et einstein a sans doute était
très inspiré par tous ces problèmes
d'ingénierie et s'est posé une question
mais est ce qu'il est vraiment possible
de synchroniser des montres est ce qu'il
existe vraiment un temps universel bon
je suis pas sûr qu'il ait vraiment posé
chose dans cet ordre là
toujours est il qu'il en est venu à se
poser la question de la nature du temps
et de l'espace
ce qu'il fera dans la théorie de la
relativité en utilisant comme hypothèse
le fait qu'il a une vitesse de la
lumière est la même pour tout ce qui est
une vitesse maximale de la causalité
l'az emploi qui il a supposé ça c'est
parce qu'ils interprètent la la théorie
de maxwell comprend les équations
actuelle enfin jean retranchements
référentiel la vitesse de la lumière
reste la même et einstein s'additionner
ce n'est pas juste une étrangeté de la
théorie de maxwell c'est peut-être
quelque chose de fondamental dans notre
monde physique alors leurs activités au
sein sur un truc fou comme après un
épisode 5 mais aussi
parler pas mal de ses conséquences comme
par exemple la nonna l'itv td vitesse
dans un présent épisode 3 la contraction
des longueurs d'onde un appareil dans
l'épisode 4 puis après dans l'épisode 7
à nouveau ou encore la dilatation du
temps dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 23
et ce papier là tout seul c'est une
révolution de la physique c'est un
papier pour lequel einstein aurait était
devenu incroyablement connu déjà c'était
en 1905 mais en 1905 c'est l'année
miraculeuse d'einstein une année
absolument incroyable où ce papier là
cette invention la relativité restreinte
n'était qu'un qu'une des quatre très
grandes découvertes de l'année
et le plus fou c'est que les quatre
découvertes venaient d'une seule et même
personne
albert einstein donc une autre
découverte qui est très relié à la
relativité restreinte puisque avec une
conséquence de l'hypothèse que la
vitesse de la lumière les mêmes pour
tous c'est les cautions égalem shaker
dance est apparu dans l'épisode 6 qui
est une explication de l'origine de la
masse inertielle et une chaîne pose la
question qui paraît insensé à un moment
où il écrit qui paraît même insensé bien
après et dont on ne comprend vraiment
tous les aspects que bien plus récemment
un tournant avec le mécanisme de higgs
et la théorie qcd de la chromodynamique
un einstein pose la question dans cet
article c'est le titre est-ce que
l'inertie dans le corps ne serait pas
juste une propriété émergents du fait
qu'avant tous les objets sont des
concentrations de l'énergie et simon
confine de l'énergie en un point de
l'espace-temps n'obtient un truc qui est
difficile à déplacer dans le sens où la
résistance à l'accélération de cet objet
est grande et cette résistance à
l'accélération ce qu'on appelle
l'inertie
c'est ce qu'on mesure avec la masse
appelle parfois la masse inertielle et
donc là une chaîne pose déjà la question
de l'origine de la masse une question
qui va revenir de façon récurrente au
cours du 20e siècle et qui aujourd'hui
encore est pas tout à fait résolus j'ai
mécanisme de higgs qui permet de donner
de la masse
aux particules aux fermiers aux
opposants mais il se trouve que la
plupart de la masse de nos corps ne
vient pas de cette masse travers le
mécanisme de higgs
la plupart de cette masse vient du chant
lui au nic et en fait c'est même un
problème de recherche mathématique que
de prouver le fait que le champ des
gluons acquiert bien de la masse parce
que l'on conflit n'a travers des blue
bulls les boules de bullion
et ça ça correspond à l'un des sept
problèmes du millénaire mme la
conjecture de yagg mills
ok donc ça fait déjà deux théories
révolutionnaires une qui révolutionne
espace temps et l'autre qui révolutionne
la masse ensuite einstein va écrire un
papier sur le mouvement brownien qui va
être la découverte éventuelle l'argument
qui va convaincre la communauté
scientifique de résistance des atomes
encore l'idée absolument incroyable ses
idées tellement einstein jens que faire
une chaîne c'est qu'ils étudient
théoriquement avec une hypothèse
l'hypothèse de l'existence des atouts un
quelque chose de deux phénomènes vis
quelque chose qui a été observé au début
du xviie siècle donc sans en avoir une
cheville par un mix appelé burn on
appelle du coup le mouvement brownien
qui correspond au fait que lorsque vous
mettez des grains de pollen dans un
verre d'eau même si le verre d'eau a
l'impression que l'eau ne bouge pas le
cas de wayne lui va bouger de façon
erratique les chaotiques et einstein
explique cela par le fait que l'eau est
composé de plein de petites particules
donc qu'on appellera des molécules
d'aujourd'hui qui vont dans tous les
sens et m6 de façon globale lorsque
moyenne 10 tout ça et qu'on regarde
verre d'eau et on a l'impression que
l'eau ne bouge pas en fait il ya plein
de particules qui vous ont tous les sens
c'est particulière qui en cognant les
grains de plein front faire bouger les
grandes plaines de façon erratique
ericsson analyse le mouvement des grains
de pollen pour un ferrer la taille des
particules et le nombre de particules
donc il calcule ainsi le nombre
d'avogadro puis il ya encore un autre
papier pour finir avec cette année
merveilleuses miraculeuses c'est le
papier sur la découverte des fautes ont
des atomes de lumière le fait que la
lumière est composé de d'atomes
indivisible donc on n'appelle pas ça des
atomes de lumière on a plutôt des peco
un tas de lumière ou ou des photons tout
ça c'est des synonymes
l'argument d'einstein pour l'existence
des photons est une explication de
l'effet photoélectrique donc l'effet
photoélectrique célébrer selon un
circuit mont qui arrive que certaines
propriétés et est ce qu'on a remarqué
c'est lorsque l'on est clair une plaque
de métal dans le réseau dans le circuit
électrique de avec de la lumière bleue
alors il ya un courant qui induit mais
si on l'est clair avec de la lumière
rouge
il n'y a pas de courant qui induit
loisirs que c'est parce que la lumière
rouge et pas assez puissante
du coup on pourrait augmenter la
puissance de lumière rouge on pourrait
mettre en lumière rouge extrêmement
puissante et bien ce qu'on observe c'est
que peu importe la puissance de la
lumière rouge elle n'induit pas de
courant électrique
alors que on peut mettre un tout petit
peu de lumière bleue serait un créer un
courant électrique est l'explication de
line stein c'est que la lumière est
faite de photons de petits grains de
lumière de deux photons
visible et chaque photon possède une
énergie qui dépend de sa couleur donc
les photons bleus ont beaucoup d'énergie
et du coup ils vont pouvoir exciter les
électrons des atomes et les arracher des
atomes alors que les lumières rouges ont
besoin d'avoir beaucoup de fautes ont
aucun de ses fautes on aura l'énergie
suffisante pour lui tirer les électrodes
en atone j'ai un petit peu parlé de ces
photons dans l'épisode 8 qui permettait
aussi d'introduire les espèces
vectorielles et donc cette année en 1905
un chêne pubis et leucate papier qui
chacun mérite son prix nobel chacun
révolutionne vraiment la physique c4
papier vraiment merveilleux je sais même
pas le calme des quatre est mon préféré
mais tout passe complètement inaperçue
personnes sur site einstein personne ne
soutient et jeté à une personne ne
demande à rencontrer einstein et pendant
deux ans einstein il continue à valider
des brevets tel un mec lambda inconnu
que ça les empêche pas de rêvasser et en
alors qui est encore dans son bureau des
brevets il va rêvasser à un mec qui
tombe d'un immeuble comment parler dans
l'épisode 17 et il va se dire que
quelqu'un qui tombe d'un bâtiment est en
chute libre et en apesanteur ils ne sont
plus présentes heure du coup il n'y a
plus de gravité dans son référentiel et
là il fait 10 à métier ça c'est le
référentiel sa référence elle qui ne
nécessite pas que l'on invente une force
de gravité donc cette accélération vers
le haut du ca sert a une idée absolument
lumineuse qui vas tu vas lui enfin c'est
ce qu'il va appeler l'idée la plus
heureuse de sa vie il vous invite à
aller voir l'épisode 19 aux gens parlent
pas mal mais surtout l'épisode
my fort cents sur la création garderie
du sol encore une fois à travers ses
vidéos jeux vous cherche pas à vous
convaincre d'une vérité mixage m'en fous
ce qui m'intéresse c'est vous faire
réfléchir à cette idée mais surtout vous
rendre heureux en philosophant sur cette
idée c'est une volumineuse
bon alors il a cette idée absolument
heureuse mais comme vous l'imaginez sa
convainc personne
surtout qu'il n'ya pas encore une
théorie de la courbure de l'espace du
temps du coup il ya des trucs qui
marchent pas l'impression que la terre
grossit en effet faire mieux sans cet
art einstein ne voyez pas les plus voir
dans cette théorie parce qu'il voyait le
problème de la terre qui grossit sans
doute mais il sentait qu'il avait
quelque chose d'important là il sentait
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui fait
développer l'année suivante il se fait
enfin repéré notamment par max planck à
max planck qui a déjà travaillé sur des
idées similaires aux photons même si bak
sung qui était quand même pas mal à côté
de la plaque et qu'il croyait même pas à
ce qu'il écrivait max planck rockingham
le génie d'einstein pour voir bien pensé
les choses
et du coup le recommandé puis action va
enfin avoir des positions académique qui
correspond à son génie d'abord à berne
puis à berlin où il va travailler
notamment sur quelques points quantiques
rien de très révolutionnaire à ce moment
là et gardent kane dans un coin de sa
tête le problème de l'accès ration 10
vers le haut du sol d'une mais dit-il
mais dit me dit ça et puis sans doute
alors je sais pas exactement comment il
est venu je n'ai pas à le trouver de
bons documents qui expliquait comment
est-ce qu'un chien est venu à être
persuadés de la courbure de l'espace
temps d'avoir rien de très convaincant à
mon sens mais moi j'imagine l'hypothèse
la plus probable à mon sens c'est que il
s'est dit que ses observateurs en chute
libre sont dans les bons référentiel ces
référentiels sont inertielle mais c'est
des référentiels qui sont en
accélération après les uns par rapport
aux autres et lan stone se dit il doit y
avoir une façon de dire qu'en fait on ne
peut pas comparer des référentiels
inertial qui sont trop éloignés les
autre et ça ça correspond exactement à
dire que l'espace temps et courbes comme
j'en ai parlé dans l'épisode 18 et dans
les commentaires de l'épisode 24
du coup ils commencent à être petit à
petit persuadé que sa solution c'est une
courbure de l'espace temps
sauf qu'à l'époque il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'experts mondiaux qui maîtrise la
géométrie malienne il en connaît un
c'est marcel grossman qui était son
professeur le
polytechnique de zurich donc il séchait
les cours mais du coup il retourne à
zurich pour travailler avec grossman sur
une théorie de la courbure de l'espace
temps comme j'en ai parlé dans l'épisode
vend donc à les grossman il arrive à
développer une théorie et en 1913
einstein et grossmann publie une
nouvelle théorie de la gravité de qui
passent par cette idée de courbure de
l'espace-temps ensuite en 1914 et la
première guerre mondiale qui éclate et
avoir cette première guerre mondiale
déjà chacun des camps se préparent et la
première guerre mondiale et du coup
einstein observent certains de ses
collègues qu'il admirait comme
l'ex-planque se mettre à mettre en place
à construire de nouvelles armes de plus
en plus meurtrière et einstein et
déteste ça il est affolée l'essai de
lancer une pétition au sein de la
communauté scientifique pour dire non à
la guerre mais il n'y a pas beaucoup de
signatures et il est complètement
stupéfait de de toute cette technologie
de toutes ces sciences qui sont utilisés
pour tuer d'autres personnes
le pire étant sans doute haber frites
dont il pensait à parler dans cet
épisode une autre chose qui va se passer
c'est que en chine pour promouvoir sa
théorie il va faire un peu différents
endroits en europe en allemagne en
particulier du valais à berlin et puis à
göttingen du coup il va se séparer
spatialement 2000 va de sa femme cet
éloignement spatiale va se traduire
ensuite en un événement émotionnel
puisqu'ils vont finir par se séparer et
par divorcer des années après par comme
einstein semble avoir perdu la guerre
contre les premières einstein
trouvent refuge dans l'est dans la
physique et va se lancer à ce moment
pleinement dans les études plus
détaillées de sa théorie de la
relativité
il va se rendre compte notamment que la
théorie qu'il a développée avec grossman
ne tient pas la route
et puis va aller à gauche à droite avec
en parler avec d'autres scientifiques et
c'est trouver des solutions il raconte
dans une lettre que le seul qui arrivait
à le suivre dans ses raisonnements
c'était un certain david île déserte et
à ce moment là
une course qui commence entre les deux
grands génies entre einstein à ibm pour
savoir qui sera le premier à trouver la
bonne équation de la relativité générale
alors ce que je n'ai pas raconter dans
l'épisode 20 sec en fait ces îles berthe
le premier à trouver la bonne équation
et il publie sa trois jours avant
einstein qui publie aussi la bonne
équation
mais le fait le papier des libertés est
incomplet imprécis les à réécrire et du
coup en fait ils berd va reconnaître
qu'einstein est le père de cette théorie
va donner tous les crédits einstein et
il va dire que c'est la théorie de la
médecine chinoise c'est la théorie
d'einstein est ce qui manque c'est qu'il
berd va se mettra directement enseigné
la théorie en iran tiens voici ce qu'a
découvert einstein comme si c'était déjà
une théorie établie ce qu'est ce qui est
vraiment marrant parce qu'à ce moment-là
aprilia aucune qu'il ya une preuve
expérimentale en tout cas mais d'un côté
le fait qu'elle explique la trajectoire
de mercure mais surtout la consistance
l'élégance mathématiques de cette
théorie fait que
ces deux génies là qu'ils ont beaucoup
étudié la question sont persuadés de sa
véracité avant même toute observations
expérimentales skis et ski quand même
assez intéressant d'un point de vue
épistémologique de voir l'importance de
l'élégance mathématiques en tout cas
auprès de ces génies et moi
personnellement je suis complètement
séduit aussi par les arguments
d'einstein à ce moment là je pense que
si j'avais compris tout ce qu'avait dit
einstein à ce moment là j'aurais été moi
aussi persuadé de la validité de cette
théorie est juste une théorie trop trop
trop belle la politique et générale
contrairement à la mécanique quantique
l'observation expérimental que confirmer
la relativité générale d'einstein
c'est celle-là d'ellington comme
l'appareil dans l'épisode 20 mais ce
dont je n'ai pas parlé dans l'épisode 20
c'est que il y avait beaucoup de remises
en cause de la preuve expérimentale de
d'ellington notamment pour des raisons
politiques
il faut savoir que edington était
anglais et pacifiste du coup pour
edington ils trouvaient ça absolument
génial pour le futur du monde pour
restaurer la paix dans le monde est un
peu unifier tous ces peuples qui s'en
[ __ ] plein la gueule de tout ses poils
de nationalisme edington se dit que la
science et la physique en particulier
peut être la chose qui va unifier tous
les peuples et est transcendé saisi
d'antiterrorisme nationalisme qui selon
edington herinstein sont les causes de
la guerre donc c'est pour ça que hinton
taissy motivé pour aller faire des
observations
mais c'est aussi pour ça que d'autres
personnes ont
supposez que clinton avait faussé un
petit peu c'est ces mesures ou du moins
avait été victime de façon plus ou moins
consciente d'un certain biais c'est très
difficile il y avait des biens
cognitives comme ça qui sont très
difficile même si on connaît les biais
cognitif c'est très difficile de s'en
séparer que d'autant qu'au même moment
il y avait un observateur américain
william campbell qui avait lui fait même
les mêmes mesures
mais avait conclu l'exact opposé il
avait rejeté la théorie de la relativité
générale d'einstein et donc c'est assez
marrant parce qu'en 1919
tous les journaux titrent einstein
einstein a tué newton pousse à tout le
monde mais en ukraine en super store
mais dans la communauté scientifique
donc on ne sait pas encore les gens sont
encore très dubitatif einstein n'est pas
encore vraiment une super star dans le
académique alors qu'il est déjà dans le
monde non académique ça c'est marrant
donc finalement en 1921 camp belge cette
fois fait des mesures vraiment n'être
vraiment précise vraiment convaincante
et confirme la théorie de la relativité
générale d'einstein einstein gagne du
coup le prix nobel en 1921 mais pas pour
ses travaux sur la reggina ils le
gagnent pour ses travaux sur la
mécanique quantique sur des corps du
photon est le plus fou dans toute cette
histoire c'est que suite à ce prix nobel
enfin ces découvertes et tout ça il va
avoir une nouvelle génération de
scientifiques qui vont vouloir suivre
des passionnés vont embrasser la
physique tôt que sans doute s'engager
dans l'armée ou quelque chose comme ça
les gens croient en les sciences à ce
moment là et les sciences sont devenus
quelque chose d'incroyablement sexy
cette époque
du coup on a toute une génération de
dire halte schrödinger paoli max born de
breiz maïorana fermi et puis surtout un
certain niels bohr qui va devenir le
nouveau né mais six d'einstein donc tous
ces gens là vont développer au cours des
années 20 et 30
la théorie de la mécanique quantique va
super bien marché qui va expirer plein
de faits expérimentaux mais qui va
extrêmement déranger einstein einstein a
toujours cru à mes clients tic mais son
problème avec les clients tic c'est pas
la véracité de mes cliques quantique
c'est le fait que ce n'est pas une
théorie fondamentale selon einstein en
effet mécanique quantique
elle utilise des probabilités pour
prédire certains événements et einstein
dit que l'utilisation des probabilités
est une preuve de notre ignorance
utilisent des probabilités passe quelque
chose qui n'a pas compris et du coup
lorsque moyenne 10 voix ont finalement
la tuerie est effectivement marche
mais si on est capable de décrire plus
en profondeur les les particules et tout
ça on serait ce donc et einstein capable
de tout prédire c'est ce qu'il va
appeler la théorie des variables cachées
ce père qui est des variables ils des
trucs en plus dans la théorie qu'on n'a
pas encore introduit dans nos modèles
théoriques et qu'ils vont être capables
de d'enlever les probabilités de la
mécanique quantique ça ça correspond à
ce qu'elle avait écrit dans une lettre
au fait que dieu ne joue pas aux dés
selon einstein en particulier un
problème qui gênait beaucoup einstein et
qui - personnes enfants de dérange
beaucoup aussi et je pense qu'il dérange
beaucoup beaucoup de physiciens
peut-être pas assez à mon sens mais que
fait cacher des choses très bizarres
c'est le problème de la mesure le fait
que lorsque l'on mesure quelque chose
qu'on observe un objet quantique son
état quantique se modifie l'observation
affecte l'état quantique de ce qu'on
observe et sa and stones c'est leur
révolte complètement board dit juste
c'est la théorie c'est comme ça ils
cherchent pas à savoir plus en
profondeur et en chine dit mais il ya un
truc qui marche pas les manières truc
qui est bizarre là il faut réussir à me
l'expliquer faut faire une théorie qui
non seulement prédit bien mais qui en
plus doit vraiment avoir un sens
un sens derrière tout 5 rue einstein
disait j'aime penser que la lune est là
même lorsque je ne la regarde pas ça
correspond à dire que si on est
complètement bord si on est si on suit
ce qu'on appelle l'interprétation de
copenhague parce que bord et danois si
on en croit la l'interprétation de
copenhague
les objets n'ont vraiment leur état que
lorsqu'on les observe et du coup
lorsqu'on observe pas la lune
elle peut être dans un état quantique
qui n'est pas le même que lorsqu'on
observe et du coup elle apparaît
vraiment le cas selon l'interprétation
copenhague ont poussé à son extrême la
lune n'a paraît vraiment que lorsqu'on
la regarde à ce qui est très bizarre
du coup einstein va à plusieurs reprises
essayé d'attaquer la mécanique quantique
en montrant qu'il ya un truc qu'on n'a
pas compris dans la mécanique quantique
et donc il ya plusieurs attaques et qui
fait ça et à chaque fois c'est bord doit
beaucoup à réfléchir pour résoudre ce
paradoxe apparent et le plus mythique de
tout cela c'est sans doute celui de ceux
de la confiance de solvay en 1930
richard propose expansion tu prenais une
boîte fermée avec une petite fenêtre mes
fenêtres fermées au début et puis vous
ouvrez la fenêtre pendant un court
instant
du coup il ya peut-être quelques photos
qui sont sortis et s'il ya des photons
qui sortent de la boîte
ça veut dire que là comme eux est égal à
mc quarrie ça veut dire que ces photons
là on m'a enlevé de l'énergie du coup il
ya moins d'énergie dans la boîte du coup
la masse de la boîte devrait avoir
diminué sauf carrington dit que la
variation de la masse donc l'énergie qui
est parti ça a priori on peut le mesurer
avec une barbe et une précision
arbitraire de mesurer avec une très
grande précision la masse de la boîte
avant d'avoir ouvert la fente on peut
mesurer avec grande précision la masse
de la boîte
après avoir ouvert la fente donc
l'incertitude que l'on a sur l'énergie
qui lie à l'intérieur abbott est en fait
aussi petit que l'on veut alors que la
durée d'ouverture de la fente est
également aussi petit que l'on veut du
coup le produit entre l'incertitude sur
le temps d'ouverture et l'incertitude
sur l'énergie qui s'en est allé ça a
priori on peut le rendre aussi petit que
l'on veut et ça ça contredit les
principes fondamentaux de la physique
quantique
et en particulier le principes
d'étalement de heisenberg c'est carla
qui l'appelle principe d'incertitude moi
je préfère appeler ça un principe des
talents rozenfeld a écrit à ce sujet
c'était un vrai choc pour bord qui au
début n'avait pas de solution à ce
problème d'einstein et pendant le reste
de la soirée au congrès il était
incroyablement agitée et il continuait
de passer entre d'un scientifique à
l'autre avant de chercher à les
persuader qu'ils ce que disait einstein
ne pouvait pas être vrai mais il n'y
avait pas des beaux-arts musulmans et
que ce serait la fin de la physique si
einstein avait raison ça vous détruisez
complètement en tout cas la physique
quantique
mais bon on n'arrivait pas à trouver de
façon de résoudre le paradoxe je ne
pourrai jamais oublier l'image des deux
antagonistes ça c'est rozenfeld qui
parle au moment ils ont quitté le
congrès
einstein avec son grand air confiant
avec sa tranquillité et son rire un peu
ironique du bord complètement agitée à
côté de lui qui arrêtait pas de bouger
dans tous les sens avec grande
excitation à ce moment là on avait
l'impression que je vais gagner mais
rosenthal rajoute le matin suivant ce
fut le triomphe de bord
l'explication de boire est un peu
technique son grand défi c'est de relier
l'incertitude sur la variation de masse
à une incertitude sur le temps
d'ouverture de la fenêtre
hélas qui scelle beauté du raisonnement
de bord si tu as utilisé la théorie de
la relativité générale d'einstein en
disant que lorsqu'on cherche à peser la
boîte on peut utiliser par exemple une
balance mais l'incertitude sur la
position fait qu une incertitude sur la
mesure de la masse en fait on peut pas
mesurer la masse de façon infiniment
précise en tout cas pas si on recherche
la mesurer en utilisant l'accélération
des référentiels
sauf que du coup si on fait ça par
exemple sur terre l'incertitude sur la
position sur la hauteur de la boîte
correspond à des variations de la
dilatation gravitationnelle du temps et
cette variation sur la dilatation
gravitationnelle du temps crée une
incertitude sur la mesure du temps qui
est donc lié à la position
l'argument est juste incroyable bond
utilise la relativité générale pour
résoudre le paradoxe de mécanique
quantique qui avait posé einstein plus
tenus
nous aussi dit la bataille borenstein
n'est pas fini on va en parler d'un
autre débat à la fin de cette vidéo
en 1933 le régime nazi accède au pouvoir
en allemagne et puis à stein qui est
pacifiste mais qui aussi juif est
contraint de s'échapper
il va fuir aux états unis notamment à
princeton university où il va former à
une espèce de dream team ii d'un
instituteur battus 27 à 10 là bas avec
notamment les von neumann gödel herman
van loo encore paoli et à cette occasion
il va acquérir la 6e nationalité de sa
vie est ce que c'est vrai pour quelqu'un
qui qui n'aimait pas le nationalisme
parce que justement c'est lié au fait
que la nationalité mon sentiment
nationaliste il a commencé avec la
nationalité de du royaume de wittenberg
puis il est devenu apatride puis suisse
puis austro hongrois puis prusse prusse
sait vraiment quoi et enfin il est
devenu américain en allant aux états
unis à princeton
il va écrire ensuite une lettre au
président roosevelt des états unis pour
lancer un projet de bombe nucléaire que
je qualifierais ce qu'on appellera le
projet manhattan à une chaîne avait
notamment peur que du côté nazis comment
un mec comme aaron berg ne n'en vienne à
construire cette bombe nucléaire
avant les américains mais il finira pas
regretter ses recherches la monuc a
surtout son utilisation à hiroshima et
nagasaki et enfin en 1935 le paradoxe
inter qui a un énorme ce chapitre dans
la rivalité einstein versus bord ou
einstein va gagner le débat
à mon sens en tout cas il va écrire un
papier absolument incroyable dans lequel
il va montrer que en construisant des
particules intriquées en les
en de très loin ces particules
intriquées si on en croit la mécanique
quantique de base en tout cas elle devra
avoir une interaction à distance plus
rapide que celle de la vitesse de la
lumière
du coup heineken disent assez
contradictoire avec la relativité
restreinte
du coup la mécanique quantique telle
qu'elle était formulée dans
l'interprétation de copenhague est
incomplète et il propose notamment de
rajouter des variables cachées qui
déterminent la manière dont les
particules vont être observés au moment
où les particules sont se sont séparés
et pas après ce qu'on appelle la théorie
des variables cachées locale et là c'est
le triomphe d'einstein l'argument est
implacable
je pense qu'à ce moment là n'importe
quel théoriciens qui réfléchissent à
cette question donne raison à einstein
sauf que l'histoire est plus compliqué
et plus merveilleuse encore que tout ça
puisque dans un 50 là bas il ya un
mathématicien john bell qui a découvert
des inégalités de bell qui permettent de
distinguer entre la théorie des
variables cachées local d'einstein et
l'interprétation de copenhague de la
mécanique quantique et john bell va
donner une façon de mesurer sa va
falloir attendre les premiers
technologique pour y arriver mais dans
les années 80 des expériences d'alain
respect montré que la navette aura qui
en fait une interaction à distance plus
rapide en un certain sens quelle vitesse
de la lumière mais ça ne contredit pas
le principe de relativité et la vitesse
maximale de la lumière parce qu'il n'est
pas possible d'influencer le résultat de
l'autre en modifiant l'état de l'ain et
du coup il n'est pas possible d'envoyer
d'informations plus rapide que la
vitesse de la lumière mais c'est
vraiment vraiment soult il peut dire que
einstein c'est s'est trompé mais avec
raison car comme je le dis dans
l'épisode sur les erreurs à dire vrai
sans raison triomphe sans gloire et à
dire faux avec raison c'est ce que je
pense
on s'incline avec une gloire triomphante